[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 30 mai
groupes locaux et tête d'affiche vous
donne rendez vous ce samedi à voisins le
bretonneux c'est la deuxième édition de
la tour mais les boîtes 10 heures de
musique et dix artistes
on lui doit la rénovation de notre-dame
de paris et de la cité de carcassonne
eugène viollet le duc émettent aussi
voyagé plusieurs de ses dessins sont
actuellement exposé à versailles
et ce week-end c'est aussi la 7e édition
du festival etc les cinémas cette année
18 films sont en compétition le rendez
vous est donné pour le 2 juin
et c'est justement avec ce festival que
commence magazine notre invité
christelle bidoire bonjour je veux être
la responsable de l'espace philippe
murray alors ce samedi c'est la septième
édition du festival exhale ont démarré
la 7e c'est un festival qui fonctionne
bien d'année en année on arrive à avoir
de plus en plus de public et énormément
de candidatures donc on est très heureux
de pouvoir pérenniser cette
manifestation
dix-huit films sont en compétition vous
avez reçu près 80 candidatures est ce
que ça n'a pas été trop dur de faire un
choix
c'est toujours très difficile de faire
un choix pour le jury le jury de
sélection au lieu de 80 films qu'elle
quitterait re privilégié il ya quand
même aussi des critères subjectifs qui
appartiennent à chacun
donc je sais que c'est un gros travail à
chaque fois est l'objet de grosses
discussions entre les différents membres
du jury de présélection
justement comment est-ce que déjà la
présélection ce fait est ce qu ils font
part sur un thème une sensation
l'actualité qui peut faire les cours dès
fois aucune thématique ne demander au
réalisateur on a un appel à courre
la seule contrainte est le 16 minutes
maximum pour respecter un nombre sur
trois heures de projection l'idée quand
même de multiplier le nombre de courts
métrages dont caen avec des courts
métrages 20 minutes on arrive vite à 3h
l'idée aussi de pouvoir proposer plus de
choix encore au public et quand à quant
à la sélection c'est toujours un peu il
ya quand même une question technique on
soigne le cadrage
le scénario est également le jeu des
acteurs beaucoup de choses rentrent
rentrer en jeu et certains reviennent
d'année en année oui cette année
cette année est ce le cas il me semble
bien que oui et on a des réalisateurs
qui reviennent alors est-ce que ça
s'explique peut-être parce que les clés
sous boss aussi est ce qu'on peut faire
une paire de cinéma beaucoup de
créateurs de jeunes se lancent son deck
les siens se sont lancés un espace
uniquement avait alors certains on a
aussi deux un réalisateur d'origine
mabrouk el mechri qui vient de la ville
des clayes-sous-bois qui nous a fait
l'honneur de parrainer notre festival il
ya quelques éditions déjà et puis le
festival puis de pardonnez moi l'espace
philippe noiret et investi dans le
cinéma au quotidien de part évidemment
son activité principale est aussi par
toutes les actions d'éducation à l'image
auprès des scolaires donc le court
métrage intègre aussi cette volonté de
donner à voir le plus de cinéma possible
pour tous les publics
parce que le court métrage en rappel
c'est un art cinématographique l'on
mettra non pas du tout c'est quelque
chose qui doit être précis concis
efficace ça demande une maîtrise de la
grammaire cinématographique justement
pour arriver à raconter une histoire en
peu de temps
donc non non c'est qui c'est un vrai
exercice de cinéma le court métrage est
souvent les grands noms comme encelade
ce parmi les réalisateurs qui se lance
chez vous souvent ils sortent de l'école
où ils sont encore en étude donc le
style associé à présent faire connaître
exactement c'est aussi le
un moyen pour des réalisateurs de
montrer leur premier travail c'est un
petit monde aussi il y a beaucoup de
festivals de grands festivals aussi
comme celui de clermont ferrand et c'est
oui c'est une porte d'entrée pour
beaucoup de réalisateurs et vous de
temps en temps vous allez chercher les
réalisateurs où ils ne font que se
présenter eux ont fait une passe par un
appel à courre
le recrutement des réalisateurs se fait
essentiellement et principalement et
surtout d'ailleurs par un appel à corps
vous le disais tout à l'heure
certains noms prestigieux du cinéma sont
membres du vote du jury et pardon ce
sont chaque année des professionnels
exhumant disney m'a alors cette année
c'est tellement long
nous avons le l'honneur d'accueillir
muriel tire un qui est productrice et
qui sera la présidente du jury qui
donnera donc sa couleur et c'est sa
couleur au jury on a la chance d'avoir
marines un cilic et comédienne qu'on
peut voir dans section de recherches sur
une chaîne comme ça y est on a aussi une
réalisatrice scénariste malika hadjal
c'est un jury très féminin sept ans est
scolarisé dans l'actualité
cinématographique
c'est le hasard c'est le hasard et moi
évidemment tant que femme très contente
de ce hasard
non non c'est un hasard sur les six à
sept membres on a cinq femmes dont notre
élu l'élu de la ville des
clayes-sous-bois la culture and dale est
également un membre de la sky est donc
un jury très féminin
ce qui me plaît énormément évidemment
alors l'an dernier président du jury
c'était le scénariste philippe berna et
nous confier que le premier critère pour
ovi pour élire le gagnant
c'était l'émotion est ce que vous le
ressentez vous depuis cette édition où
c'est vraiment très personnelle du
cinéma c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
très personnel
le cinéma est un film de cinéma un court
métrage comme un long métrage est une
oeuvre d'art
au même titre qu'une
qu'un tableau aucune photographie donc
l'idée quand même d'arriver à créer des
émotions chez le spectateur est ce que
ça résonne ce que ça résonne chez lui
donc oui c'est un critère important est
ce que ça nous touche comment quelles
émotions et puis après comment l'émotion
évidemment et mise en scène est en mise
en scène et en images donc on à
l'émotion et puis pour beaucoup y allant
de jules verne est aussi une donnée
évidemment technique de technicité du
cinéma est ce que chaque année m'envoyer
des courts métrages qui se renouvelle
avec toujours plus d'imagination des
sujets reviennent comme comme pour le
cinéma ou les séries l'informatique a
ouvert tellement de possibilités que oui
déjà que c'est un exercice qui se veut
inventif le court métrage de par sa
durée et oui effectivement beaucoup de
beaucoup de nouvelles idées beaucoup de
nouvelles choses
alors qui est des festivals d un prix à
la fin il y en a un qui est prestigieux
justement c'est le prix du jury
mais il ya un pur est quelqu'un qui
n'est pas oublier c'est le public fait
l'objet son mot à dire il ya aussi oui
c'est important
c'est important on a trois prix trois
prix du jury exactement premier prix 2e
prix et troisième prix meilleur que le
meilleur comédien la meilleure
comédienne sont exactes également
récompensé effectivement voulait laisser
une place au public le meilleur moyen
c'est de pouvoir lui donner la
possibilité de voter de s'exprimer et
donner son avis sur un court métrage
alors pour se donner un avant goût de ce
qui va pouvoir être diffusé le samedi de
juin on regarde la bande annonce
[Musique]
je ne
on voit qu'il ya de tout oui des
passages un peu dans le passé on a un
bel échantillonnage la de tout ce qu'on
peut avoir on a vu une marionnette on a
vu aussi du un passage au noir et blanc
avec des effets des effets des effets de
caméra
c'est un très bon teaser qui montre bien
toute la richesse de la programmation
des 18 courts qu'on propose samedi
est-ce que
on va revenir un peu ce qu'on disait un
peu avant est ce que le court métrage
c'est aussi une passerelle pour le long
que vous vous retrouvez peut-être des
réalisateurs au festival beaucoup de
réalisateurs
de longs sont passés par le court mais
tous les réalisateurs de courts
n'ambitionne pas forcément de passer par
le long métrage se
certains d'eux
certains de nos lauréats 6 on s'y sont
essayés le sont envers en tout cas sont
en voie de sont en voie de le faire
certains se spécialisent carrément dans
le court métrage ils ont trouvé leur
coup de coeur alors le festival ce ne
sont pas que des projections coc détente
des changes oui exactement donc sur les
trois heures de projection ces trois
heures de projection par n'en sont
divisés en deux et un échange est prévu
avec les réalisateurs à l'issue de
chaque de chaque projection de deux
personnes seront sur scène et
questionneront les réalisateurs sur
certains aspects de leur film j'aime
aller c'est aussi un temps attendue par
les réalisateurs ça permet de défendre
c'est vrai qu'il peut de par an et entre
permettre défendre ça permet aussi de
comment dire de donner un regard
supplémentaire ou un autre regard sur
son court métrage
il est possible aussi d'échanger avec
eux pour le public
après les cessions puisque il ya un bar
dans le jury délibère un bar est
organisée dans le hall de l'espace
philippe noiret y ça peut être le moment
aussi pour le public d'échanger avec le
réalisateur puisque c'est encore un
moment qui se veut le festival des clés
du cinéma un moment d'échangés de belles
choses merci que vous allez devoir alors
les amoureux du septième art le cours
fait thiam à l'espace philippe noiret
vous attend samedi de juin la première
projection commence à 14h avec cette
exposition vous ne découvrirez pas le
viol et le duc architecte au musée
lambinet vous partez à la rencontre de
jeunes viollet le duc l'infatigable
voyageur 31 de ses dessins sont exposés
à versailles aurélie rose pour les
images
la déchirure supérieur du cratère de
l'etna eugène viollet le duc le grimp
1836 et l'immortaliser
[Musique]
par le travail sur la couleur est
absolument exceptionnelle tout en
restant d'une précision extrême par
rapport au paysage qui devant les yeux
on est vraiment à la fois dans une
saisie sur le vif et en même temps dans
un relevé qui est du kid un chatoiement
qui dunke d'un d'une préciosité
extraordinaire celui que l'on connaît
architecte était un voyageur passionné
de montagne une part de sa vie mise en
lumière au musée lambinet dans sa
nouvelle exposition elle est claire
exceptionnellement la totalité de sa
pratique et notamment sa d'architectes
donc ça nous a semblé extrêmement
important d'autant que s'il faut pas
oublier que ces dessins sont
exceptionnelles par leurs qualités
propres
donc rien pour le plaisir des yeux
c'était important de faire des mettre en
valeur mais effectivement il était
intéressant de les situer de les
resituer dans l'intégralité du travail
d'un personnage aussi important pour
pour l'architecturé française des
dessins de montagne poursuivre
l'architecte dans son cheminement dans
sa pratique du paysage des dessins la
technique légère car pris sur le vif le
crayon se mêle à la gouache l'aquarelle
[Musique]
un autodidacte qui se forme sur le
terrain qui pratiquent très tôt et très
tôt initié ou au dessin sur le motif et
pour lequel le dessin est véritablement
l'ossature temps de sa formation que sa
pratique tout au long de sa vie eugène
viollet le duc laisse derrière lui plus
de 450 dessins 31 d'autres sont à
découvrir à versailles paul avaient
prévu de voyager avec sa bien aimée mais
celle ci le quitte et décide tout même
de partir mais avec sa femme qui avec
une femme qui porte le même nom que sa
compagne alors vous en doutez le voyage
ne va pas se passer comme convenu à
l'origine un fait divers qui a inspiré
béatrice bausch est une auteure
versaillaise
elle signe ici son premier roman
homonyme et compagnie elle était
l'invitée de camille lambert
ce qui m'a titillé c'est que le fait
divers précisait que la personne qui
partait à l'homonyme en question elle
avait un fiancé jammu et c'est ce
caractère jaloux qui a fait que je vous
y a quelque chose à faire là dessus et
que la jalousie en fait tu vas aller
jusqu'à provoquer une surveillance très
rapprochés des voyageurs et donner un
petit côté comique et burlesque à l'
ensemble de l' aventure
le coup de coeur de la semaine c'est
celui de l'udc vaud quand on prend la
direction du ciné 7 à elancourt alors le
coup de coeur du fidesz est une fois
n'est pas coutume cette semaine c'est un
film de répertoire
le très connu little big man pardon fils
de 2h19 de 1971 d'arthur penn qui est
ressortie en salles en version restaurée
alors little big man faut absolument
voir ses filles
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre comme je viens de
le dire c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui
à 123 ans donc qui est au seuil de sa
vie et qui raconte son histoire
donc c'est un visage pâle qui a été
recueillie par des cheyennes je t'en
dire beaucoup plus
et qui va raconter un petit peu tous les
éléments qui ont jalonné sa vie donc
l'interprétation est extraordinaire
c'est dustin hoffman qui tient le rôle
principal
il est formidable donc évidemment les
maquillages etc etc etc surtout une
version du fus du genre western qui est
unique en son genre parce que le racing
s'apparente absolument pas aux westerns
classiques on a l'habitude de le voir
dans les salles de cinéma donc vous
n'hésitez pas c'est vendredi soir aussi
17 à 20h45 venez découvrir ou
redécouvrir little big man
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un autre festival se passe ce week-end
sur saint quentin en yvelines
lui c'est sa deuxième édition c'est la
tour mais les boîtes et cette année
encore 10 heures de musique et dix
groupes ou artistes et pour en parler
avec nous en plateau
pierre michel plançon bonjour bonjour de
l'association met à sa soeur j'imagine
que là on est sur les derniers jours
c'est de l'impatience totale
complètement puis là on est en plein
montage donc tout se passe bien donc on
est super contents aujourd'hui on a eu
pas mal de chance parce qu'il ya eu du
beau temps on s'attendait un peu à voir
de la pluie de l'orage nous a pas été le
cas
donc là j'en viens vous voyez gt1
légèrement en retard mais ça se passe
bien donc
super on n'a pas trop peur du mauvais
temps justement que capricieuse et
derniers jours les scènes sont toujours
un peu peur du mauvais temps mais bon je
croise les doigts la dernière ça s'est
bien passé et puis là je pense qu'on va
voir le beau temps alors cette année
l'ambiance sera pop dub et reggae on
part sur ça cette année
exactement on va accueillir neuf groupes
10 heures de musique de scène en plein
air voilà une programmation orienté
plutôt reggae hip hop de l'électro donc
ça va être assez festif
l'avoir vu sommé les ouates forcément y
avoir de la base donc ouais j'invite
exactement tous les saint quentinois
sont conviés à se retrouver le samedi 2
juin à l'espace culturel decauville pour
vraiment un moment une trappe festif
1 c'est l'occasion voilà de faire la
fête un peu et profiter de pas mal de
musique alors sur sept dix heures de
concert il y aura à brain damage
generation dj vadim la petite fumée
plein d'autres c'est dur de tous les
citer ouais comme on les avait
découverts ces artistes là bas c'est au
fur à mesure des années après il ya des
groupes on accompagne
puis qu'on découvre avec différents
dispositifs donc là cette année on a la
chance d'accompagner the roots anjani
par exemple qu'un groupe de reggae on a
également un master qui a été vraiment
un coup de coeur la saison dernière
d'ortiz où ça fait un petit moment qu'on
les suit mais on savait grand plaisir
qu'on les accueille du coup sûr le
festival voilà sur un événement un peu
plus important et puis generation qui
est un peu les toiles aussi montante du
reggae et bien sûr brenda metge avec
harrison stafford que le chanteur de
groundation donc là on a l'honneur
pouvoir les accueillir sur cette édition
d'avoir jamais exacte des ambiances
alors oui plus ou moins après ça
s'alternent ça qu'il ya une scène dans
le ja rien qui est peut-être à orienter
plus musique / électronique on va dire
même auster qui est qui un groupe de hip
hop mais qui tend vers aussi une musique
électronique et l'autre on est quand
même plus sur la musique on va dire
reggae à voilà
bois tout simplement comme un dernier
souvent la table à tour mais les watts
et l'idée de faire partager la sana des
groupes aguerris et des groupes locaux
qui se créent
c'est exactement ça donc c'est un peu
l'objet du festival c'est de pouvoir
montrer les groupes
voilà locaux faire découvrir ça au
public
c'est pas toujours évident de venir voir
des groupes qu'on ne connaît pas donc un
festival c'est l'occasion puis aussi de
programmer voilà des têtes d'affiché de
la scène indépendante française
donc on est sur ce créneau là c'est vrai
qu'on n'est pas trop sur la musique on
va dire mainstream on est vraiment sûr
de la découverte ce qu'on va pas voir
je ne sais pas par ma france 3 voilà
exactement pour en citer plein mais
exactement c'est la tendance ajustements
dans la cité plein l'idée c'est quand
même qu'on en découvre au moins pour le
moment c'est d'ortiz où on est plutôt un
extrait
[Musique]
cellules de batterie
l'ascension continue toujours
des marques avec l'équipe kmp telebig
pas transformer l'équipe ya un somptueux
bpt détecte pas c'est comme ça qu'un mec
taf on a mis les mêmes bars que ces
combles en apoca routard mais pas les
meilleurs puisque à la base on est comme
tout le monde
complétez vos printemps bat les et
faisait comme tout bon tout ce qu'on
sait ce qu il faut qu on pourrait tous
bon ok mais quasi tous t'ont fait péter
les pistolets mais faudra pas que tu
puisses only you tube a perdu le prix de
monde à philippe risoli pas temps
d'écouter la plupart des gens dégoûtés
mais même la plupart des clichés
d'exister cas des couples est sacré
punch sacré punch mais belle énergie sur
scène par non ça fout le feu honnêtement
je dirais même ça va bastonner de
artisous rien à d'autres on l'a laissé
des têtes d'affiché qui sont installés
dans leur métier depuis plus de 20 ans
qui sont reconnus et notamment brain
damage cette année avec harrison
stafford
ils mélangent carrément eu du reggae et
du dub on les écoute
[Musique]
ça lui parle du chan isabelle wish i met
ko
c'est
chagny
népal mais je pars
oh
ah oui j'allais
allez pas mes choix
meeting
[Musique]
on sait que souvent ce sont des artistes
qui aime mêler les gens de les faire se
rencontrer aussi vous imaginez peut-être
des coups de coeur des coups des
rencontres artistiques tout à fait
d'ailleurs brenda metge hyacinthe sa
forte c'est pas les seuls qu'on va
accueillir cette année où il ya comme ça
un peu des rencontres entre des artistes
il ya aussi dj vadim et bear head qui
vont pouvoir proposer un show ensemble
des règles de raggasonic donc voilà on a
la chance de pouvoir accueillir des
artistes comme ça cette année
on est très contents voilà pouvoir les
programmes et que le public va pouvoir
aussi les écouter les découvrir ça pour
tout vent tourner et ap tu appuies têtes
appui lh2 comme l'année dernière
alors bien sûr il ya deux scènes ya de
la musique mais il n'ya pas que ça on a
aussi un village associatif
on a un superbe arrêt sur père
restauration des toilettes sèches qui
vont mettre les ouates surprise voilà
alors voilà surprise la plus vraiment
parce que maintenant on sait voilà qu'on
a une petite scène dans les toilettes
ont fait une petite ambiance on va
accueillir six dj aussi qui met
l'ambiance donc non non c'est un sacré
événement quand même alors on a parlé
des quelques artistes bien sûr on peut
pas aller on peut pas tous les présenter
ce que le temps de temps court alors
pour tous les découvrir direction le
site internet de met asos et bien sûr
aller aller face de covile samedi de
juin merci pierre michon planches sont
devenus entre sur notre plateau mais pas
toi merci à vous tous cas ça grand
plaisir pouvoir présenter cet événement
puis ouverture des portes à 16 heures
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin donc rendez
vous le 2 juin tout à donner toutes les
informations pratiques
on change carrément d'idées on part en
littérature puisqu'il y a trente leçon
de littérature avec 30 et qui vont
écrivains dans 30 lycées c'est un
événement mis en place par la région
ile-de-france à lycée saint quentinois
était concerné le lycée jean vilar de
plaisir les élèves ont reçu l'écrivain
thomas béret verdi la semaine dernière
un temps suspendue à quelques jours du
baccalauréat le reportage est signée
malan varaldo sur des images de camille
lambert avant d'être sélectionné pour
cette rencontre littéraire les
professeurs de lettres du lycée jean
vilar
plaisir ont répondu à un appel à
candidature afin d'accueillir l'auteur
thomas béret verdi une première
importante pour leurs étudiants ça
permet aux élèves d'avoir un vrai
échange avec un auteur de rencontrer
quelqu'un qui qui vide de sa plume et
qui peut transmettre justement une
expérience d'écriture et d'écrivains
authentique mêlée de la poésie à son
oeuvre
un mélange des deux genres de l'auteur
contemporain apprécié par les sept
classes conviés à cet échange de 30
minutes
alors ce qui va beaucoup marqué c'est
vraiment l'histoire de l'auteur c'est à
dire que l'histoire de son grand-père
qui a écrit juste avant qu'il meure pour
son petit fils ça m'a vraiment touché
son ca très intéressant de comprendre
jusqu'où ils vont
inventer des choses
à toucher les autres gens par balles la
par l'écriture permettre une ouverture
d'esprit dès le lycée ne pas attendre
les master classes des universités
tel était le désir de cette rencontre
auteur lycéens ils sont précisément à
cet âge où ça se passe c'est à dire si
on les désigne maintenant je parle pas
d'en faire des dépôts est mais par
rapport à la lecture
si on les désinhibe maintenant si on
leur dit vous avez le droit d'ouvrir un
livre et de prendre plaisir à lire comme
si vous alliez au cinéma où tous à
imaginer des histoires
eh bien on les désignait pour la vie et
les étudiants pourront peut-être mettre
à profit cet échange lors de leurs
épreuves de français qui se tiendra le
18 juin de 14h à 18h
à vaincre sans péril on triomphe sans
gloire l'histoire bien célèbre de
rodrigues et shimell reprend vie au
théâtre montansier à versailles
le metteur en scène yves benot de boonen
a choisi la version 2 737 la version
originale un autre bond dans le passé
bien plus bien que plus récents à saint
cyr l'école on part dans les années 80
je te donne macumba capitaine abandonné
son programme
rendez-vous le 2 juin à 20h30 et un
autre concert dans un lieu insolite au
zoo celui de thoiry fête ses 50 ans et à
cette occasion de 10h à minuit ce sera
la première édition du happy touahri
festival visite du zoo dans la journée à
partir de 19h30 un concert avec amir
claudio capéo arcadian extraits
[Musique]
même qu'ils aient le temps
oh
mois d'août
toujours
deux mois d'août
tous les yeux
[Musique]
c
on sait pas
j'en passe
vous
[Musique]
et au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on découvre
l'invention du nouveau monde en chansons
le compositeur julien joubert nous
entraîne de la renaissance à
l'imprimerie de jeanne d'arc à
christophe colomb et l'opéra est à
écouter samedi 2 juin
voilà c'est la fin de ce site une
culture merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]